blood-sucking leeches that aren't my
ex-girlfriend face torn androids in an
episode that raises more questions than
answers we have season 2 episode 5. now
i have to apologize last week i did say
there were six episodes but imdb steered
me wrong there are eight so you can
string me up to that wall and punish me
i promise i will only find it mildly
erotic there's an insane amount to get
into here so we're gonna get right into
it and if you like these deep dives make
sure you're notified with the bell on to
be alerted as soon as they come out
paul's cocoon body is taken out of an
iso bath last episode a bio attack by
the quantum computer known as trust left
paul in this serpent-like state with
samples having been taken from the
serpent and trust having access to them
it's not a stretch to believe this
bioweapon may have been manufactured
using the serpent's dna zoo finds out
she has roughly 24 hours before the
chemicals within the cocoon dissolve
paul for good but mother notes the
cellular structure is getting stronger
it's not really death at all it's more
than
an evolution this idea of evolution and
evolution plays a strong part as we'll
see later in the episode after marcus
lost mother's eyes last episode he has
also lost its strength associated with
it thus he must take him and his
followers inland to avoid being hunted
down by mother who is almost unstoppable
in her weaponized state their goal is to
gain access to the seeds that can grow
the tree of knowledge because according
to the pentagonal prophecy those who eat
the fruit from it will be made pure and
with it he will lead his people to the
tree of knowledge
and all who eat from it will be made
pure king also happens to be the title
of this episode and the only one
referred to as such is father so if the
necromancer is queen now
does that make you the king in my last
episode breakdown we saw how father's
eyes made the same formation as mothers
when she put in those necromancer eyes
this occurred while in the presence of
the android he was creating known as
grandmother will he be able to acquire
powers like mother after all the show
has made it very clear to refer to him
as a simple service android multiple
times this season it's almost as if
they're setting him up to be something
more it was paul who theorized the tree
of knowledge needed to be grown while
analyzing the images found on this
ancient box he says the seeds can be
found in the tarantula but marcus and
his crew of believers are no match to
take it on tempus briefly mentions that
the encampment she was going to give her
baby to has fled after mother's coup
against trust this also has me wondering
if marcus will end up teeming with any
of the rival encampments seeing as
mother would be a common enemy decimal
basically lays all her cards on the
table calling marcus out as being a
false prophet but hawley and the others
aren't swayed hawley even gives marcus
an ancient methraic relic romulus's
tooth romulus was said to be the founder
of rome this tooth was something she
found in the mathrack wreckage in season
one a tooth
it was taken from the body of romulus he
and his brother were raised by a
she-wolf during their search inland they
find another dodecahedron temple similar
to the one found in season one near the
top side of the planet whatever ancient
civilization once held sway over this
planet seemed to scatter these
throughout it meanwhile mother continues
her search for holly finding what i like
to call a hologram message telling
mother and father not to look for her
holly tells veda hunter and tempest to
come and join her but notice how she
left out paul in campion she probably
thinks paul is dead and campion of
course is a non-believer but with
champion having seen the glowing entity
he now believes saul to be real soul is
in there with him father's
million-year-old android he's been
working on has finally come online or
sorta he says of this veil that covers
her eyes which is also known as a call
it would appear your call is
not your call at all but
part of your build this thing is a part
of her but why would her face need to be
shielded could it be that she too has
necromancer eyes and has them shielded
like mother would often do hunter and
tempest find father's android and are
unable to turn it on however when
tempest is alone the android's call
reflects an ultrasound of her baby we
aren't exactly sure the extent of
grandmother's powers here so far we know
she can glow fly project images and it
seems as though her body can interfere
with electronics i wonder if her
presence may offset the electromagnetic
field of the planet making the tropical
zone unprotected from whatever saul's
voice was in season 1. we'll later see
sue contacted by some sort of voice that
may or may not be solved mother's
interrogation of cleaver serves a more
philosophical purpose she states that
humans like androids can be reprogrammed
it's just done a little differently
cleaver himself was so molded through
conditioning that he forgets the name of
his brother the one whose eyes he took
he is so not the person he used to be
that mother says they're your eyes
cleaver completely helpless and on the
brink of losing paul sue prays to saul
using veda's rosary it's a last-ditch
effort so why the hell not it's ironic
that paul hated sue for not believing in
saul but now she's praying to saul to
save him for his safe return she'll do
anything he wants in the brig father
recruits lucius to help him track down
marcus and the believers you may recall
lucius as being the only one not to
follow marcus believing him to be a
false prophet in exchange for lucius's
help father promises him his freedom the
dodecahedron here has partially
collapsed allowing the believers to
reveal a dodecahedron cage lowering into
a pit it also has a small hole just like
the one on the other side of the planet
although this one doesn't seem to
spontaneously combust people it's also
important to note this temple has no
signs whatsoever of saul or the sole
invictus symbol these were likely not
temples to him aside from that justina
believes this to be some sort of trial
to be passed and that cage is filled
with all sorts of ancient symbols
including this which is known in sacred
geometry as a metatron a symbol that
represents the journey of energy
throughout the universe and a balance
within the universe it even looks like
these could be seeds within the center
this symbol was seen in episode 9 of
season 1 and similar mythic ancient
roman symbols like the star tetrahedron
here in episode 2. this idea of balance
is also interesting right now mother
holds all the power things are very out
of balance but as we theorized last
episode grandmother may be that
counterbalance sue experiences what
she'll later deem a vision from saul
these leeches attached to paul's body
which are the clue to his ailment these
same types of leeches were earlier taken
off vril when she was attacked by one of
those sea creatures with campion's help
she lures one such creature using the
voice of one of its own now i may be
crazy but this was my interpretation
look at this shot here it's almost as if
these two mothers are doing what they
need to to protect their children sue to
save paul and this creature hearing the
sound of an injured offspring meanwhile
the believers pray for marcus when
they're attacked by real who should
really be on the next episode of botched
she's on a revenge mission for what her
mother did one thing i didn't quite
understand here was how a robot could do
harm to its owner especially how it was
such a plot point a few episodes ago
about how she has to follow direct
orders perhaps her wiring got all messed
up having jumped off that cliff but if i
missed something please let me know in
the comments perhaps the biggest wtf
moment of this episode comes when marcus
finds the body of a miraculously
well-preserved creature perhaps an
ancestor of the people who lived here
millennia ago of note is the snakeskin
draped around its body similar to the
one marcus had and of which he said
stored energy could it be this energy
that kept its body intact second is a
tree of knowledge tarot car was this
person two looking for those seeds
you'll notice marcus puts this card in
his pocket so it may come back later in
episode 2 decima says of these cards
this could contain data but the weirdest
thing here is how romulus's tooth
somehow revives this creature in the
inside the episode the creator says the
particles here are actually nanobots the
tooth kind of disintegrates into these
nanobots and suddenly this creature
starts to devolve remember in season one
it stated multiple times that the
mathrack used technology from scripture
that they don't fully understand and i
think that's part of what's happening
here in a matter of seconds the being
quickly devolves into one of those
four-legged creatures we saw in season
one an interesting thing to note here is
that before the mathrake arrived in
season one father said he never saw any
creatures but after their arrival all
sorts of them begin to appear this seems
to indicate that when the mathrack
arrived whether it be their crash or
these relics it triggered something
within the planet perhaps devolving
hundreds if not thousands of these
creatures up top decima has said screw
you to holly and taken off in the tank
she'll end up being killed by her own
android daughter pretty much everyone is
killed here except for holly and marcus
both of whom will be captured by father
and lucius the leeches have miraculously
turned paul right back to normal and
mother notes that tempus baby is
livelier than normal could this have
anything to do with her interaction with
grandmother sue will have a sit down
talk with paul about how she knew about
the leeches she's unsure what it was
whether it was saul or some other power
but she knows it to be real and it
guided her the one difference here is
that in the scriptures saul would always
ask her something before he would help
this was not the case here it seems as
though pumble finally be able to forgive
sue for killing his mother and taking
over her identity since she now seems to
be a believer at least of something
something marcus predicted last episode
maybe she might come around but the
episode ends with a reintroduction of
saul's voice or at least that's what the
show wants us to believe it knows sue's
real name mary and asks of her to grow
the seeds this is likely the same voice
that told paul in season one of sue's
real identity because he too knew her
real name there's also this whole
comparison to mary in the bible who grew
the seed of god within her now this mary
is being taken to do the same thing we
just don't know exactly what this seed
is is it for a tree a human or something
else entirely the holy symbolism of mary
looking upward as if speaking to god
further nails home this point so yes we
have three more episodes until the
finale and i'm quite enjoying the season
so far as always i want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram at big story yt
until next time remember i feel we're
becoming too human
to be the parents that our children
deserve